hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well so kind of talks
about this tendency to make exceptions
before with the formulation categorical
material kind of saying that morality
has two consistent of universal laws and
they're binding on them yeah so that
means they extend to all human beings
they actually even go further and say
now you know human beings with all
rational so if you believe in as
medieval philosophers did angels and
devils presumably they would be rational
beings they have you know I understood
it being they're aliens that we ran
across and they were above the level of
the very animals they were like us and
being rational these moral laws should
apply to that one
technicals or something in place of
eyeballs or whatever so this is a very
very high stand and you might well
wonder well wait a second
human beings don't actually obey the
rules as a matter of fact more laws are
broken all the time think about
Constance why Exceptionalist you should
never lie
you should never deliberately
misrepresent things you should never
conceal the truth from somebody you're
always doing something that's not
universalizing in doing so or you know
if you use the second formulation and
always treating some of these a mere
means by lying to them so how is it then
that we human beings so walk then if
these sort of universal laws that we're
all supposed to be able to figure out
the reason why do you light it shine so
concept that we have a tendency to make
exceptions and here he's getting at
something really interested when people
make exceptions they're not saying hey I
don't think that the morality exists at
all I don't think that everybody else
can do whatever whatever they want to
what they're usually saying is everyone
else
they're bound by those moral laws and
that's so much that this case this is a
special case or I mean when doing it
this one time or well if somebody really
understood you know my motivations they
wouldn't hold me to something so strict
but everybody else should still do the
same thing so if I instituted lying I'd
say well I get the line in this case
because this is a special case and you
got to understand the special
circumstances of it or I'm the tech
person who can you know John what it's a
good line and not even like all the rest
of you go tell the truth I want you to
keep on telling the truth so it means
that recognizing according to time that
there is a universal law discoverable by
reason I'm just saying I happen to be an
exception to we didn't get a lot of
other examples think of people who cheat
on their spouses and then find out that
their spouse is you know saying screw it
you're gonna cheat on me I'm gonna cheat
on you that's suddenly they're angry at
their spouse they say you did me wrong
and you know you can look at them and
say well you did the same thing alright
so how can you complain but their
mindset is that they expect everybody
else to stick to the standards and they
make an exception for themselves
we could do this with stealing we could
do this with well you know we can even
do this with imperfect duties like being
benevolent to other people we talked
about that with the first
we'll get it in a second I should be
benevolent towards you I should you know
what I have a chance to improve your
condition your life I should do so it to
you know help out your quest for
happiness and you should do so for me
but you know if it's a bad day for I
don't have to do that but all the rest
you should matter of fact it might be a
bad day for me precisely because the
rest of you aren't doing what I expect
you to do
I'm not you did itself because I'm a
special case but the rest of you watch
it when we talk about hypocrisy
hypocrisy is very often based in this
this you know common experience of
people holding others to standards that
they themselves observe right think
about development all the rest of you
should develop your abilities to the
highest degree possible because that's
what you ought to do as rational beings
who saw this would count before I want
to lay around the house eating potato
chips drinking beer playing video games
and sleeping in as much as I want well
that that's fine for me because I'm an
exception all the rest of you want to be
productive healthy citizens of the
society that's generating all these
goods from you do you see how this how
this works this mentality I think we've
all get into this too anyway and when
other people do this doesn't it drive us
nuts that's the funny thing about it
that doesn't actually get at this but
when we see somebody else doing this we
feel a sense of something being off
kilter how can you hold other people to
to these high standards that you are not
yourself meaning it would be sort of as
if I I were to give you an example for
classes I'm not signing all sorts of
reading to do I'm not gonna actually do
that reading myself as a professor I'm
just gonna sign it to you though and
then make you write reports on it you
can teach me about you're going to trust
me to that sort of thing we didn't fight
and they got inconsistency right so what
is very on there that says that there's
a contradiction in our will in making
exceptions like this and what's the
contradiction we we see that a certain
principle should be objectively
necessary as a universal law so there's
nothing to put it in very simple terms
we think that everybody else should be
able to grasp not even reason that they
should lie that shouldn't she shouldn't
steal they should be nice to other
people all these sorts of things across
the board all these things will be
considered duties but subjectively it
should not be Universal subjectively
being with me in subject but in MIT of
exceptions what's going on there is a
contradiction willing something that is
inconsistent notice I am able to will
them consistent things the will is free
so that's a possibility for us all right
we do it we do it all the time actually
but that doesn't make it okay it doesn't
make it good so he says what are we
doing we're taking a universal law and
we're reducing it to the level the
general and his explanation for how this
happens is we're introducing empirical
considerations where we're going to do
some things that are not strictly
rational that every human being kind of
retail the things that has to do with my
own experience my own experience of my
own interpretations and desires so
there's sort of a higher-order
mix up so I haven't yet I'm saying that
for all the rest of you you should be
following reason and only reason
and figuring out what your duties are
and deciding that your actual thing to
do for myself I get to take into account
the things that are purely subjective
like what was it like my personal
desires which are not shared with you
necessarily or might be in competition
with yours they and my explanations
today obviously how this this works it's
kind of an interesting mechanism
anakata is explaining here and I think
it's very important to see how he can
say that yeah a lot of people whittle
look at things this way that here's why
their way of looking at it the screwed
up that makes us before anyone you guys
have any questions about this particular
stance taking no is all clear